we have been chronicling the Journey of
Survivor Rosemarie Melanson for five
years in fact she may have spent more
time in the hospital than anyone else so
as we approach this anniversary I talked
with her and her daughters about that
night in fact her pulse stopped and
she's convinced she died on the field
that night but the family has turned
that tragedy into Triumph
Rosemarie Melanson has come a long way
from this bedside interview sometimes
they're good days and
and some days the mother of four was at
the Route 91 Harvest Festival with her
daughters when she was hit by a single
armor-piercing bullet I looked up at the
sky and I saw no fireworks I knew right
away I saw my God we're in trouble I was
grabbing my mom's head and just
screaming screaming for her mom mom
and the last thing she said to me was
the last thing she said she couldn't
breathe her youngest daughter was hurt
too but in the chaos a sense of calm I
could feel my spirit actually leave and
actually it left my body and it is
literally levitating like 20 feet Over
My Dead Body I could see myself I'm
looking down
I said I could see the two girls looking
over me they're screaming and yelling I
could hear the bullets flying she was
one of the first shot and one of the
last to come home I was on life support
for two months and spent 13 months in a
hospital I took the bullet to the chest
it broke two ribs it punctured my lungs
it blew out the junction with the
esophagus meets the stomach went through
my stomach took out a third of my liver
and went through my spleen but somehow
she survived and reflected on those
moments in the light I was told when I
come back that I was to share these
words that we are to be kind we are to
be humble and that love is the key while
mom held on to a newfound mission
[Music]
her girls threw themselves into their
work at the family business Dance
Dynamics in downtown Summerlin it was
really important for our family to you
know be together and making sure we were
there for her recovery but at the same
time we knew that mom wouldn't want us
to give up on our dream and give up on
what we've worked literally our whole
lives for the business blossomed and The
Matriarch made it home more than a year
later
[Applause]
too many holidays in the hospital they
went on a cruise celebrated their
blessings in business and in life at the
annual Vegas strong 5K seeing her make
that progress makes everyone else that
much stronger because if she can do it
anyone else can do it the phrase
Melanson strong has become a family
motto whatever it is that you are
fighting you can get through it one day
at a time
and once again the family will be back
at the 5K again this weekend Rose Marie
has written a book you saw it there the
cover of it it's called beating the odds
with kindness humility hope and love
should be available for pre-sale later
this month